a more than one trillion dollar
infrastructure bill just got signed into
law and this is about to get bonkers we
have joe biden president united states
signing a 1.2 trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill the final step is
the passage of the largest
transportation funding package in u.s
history overall price tag 1.2 trillion
over the next eight years here are the
highlights here's where the cash is
going 110 billion dollars for bridges
and roads 39 billion to public transp uh
transit amtrak didn't even know that was
still around 666 billion dollars ev
stations and buses 12.5 billion
broadband 65 power grid 65 airports 25
billion water weighs 55 billion lead
pipes 15 billion and water
decontamination 10 billion dollars 110
billion is going to repair bridges and
173 mile 173 000 miles of roads 39
billion is for the public transit which
is going to improve accessibility and
zero emission buses then we've got the
amtrak rail maintenance and repairs 66
billion dollars five billion dollars
going for electric and hybrid school
buses 65 billion for better broadband
access in rural low income and tribal
communities more people getting high
speed internet let's do it 25 billion
dollars to spiff up airports and aging
air traffic control towers and then 15
billion dollars to replace our nation's
lead pipes now the big question is if
we're gonna spend 1.2 trillion dollars
who the hell's paying for it well uh 210
billion dollars is literally just
leftover money from covet 19 relief fund
so they had already allocated it they
didn't find a home for it so now they're
going to contribute here 53 billion is
coming from unspent unemployment
insurance allocated to the unemployment
boost and insurance didn't get spent now
coming over here crypto tax we'll get to
that in a second and then the national
deficit will grow by 256 billion dollars
over the next decade to make up the
difference everyone that was running
around on both sides of the island said
no one's gonna have to pay anything it's
cost zero dollars well the but the
deficit went up 256 billion so i don't
know how we got to it doesn't cost
anything that was a lie and then the
second thing is this crypto tax but when
you write crypto tax i'm saying oh my
god they're going to increase the taxes
right of course that's how you're going
to get more money to pay for it wrong
when you go through this here is an
overview of what's actually in this the
crypto industry concerned about a tax
reporting a requirement that's in this
bill that's what everyone was freaking
out about a couple of weeks ago and it's
because they are trying to expand the
definition of a broker for irs purposes
the bill would require all brokers to
report report transactions under the
current tax code industry proponents
worry the definitions too broad and
won't allow people such as miners and
other parties to actually comply because
they don't consider themselves
facilitating transactions they don't
have the information necessary but under
these rules you could look at it and say
why are the miners not actually
reporting this to the irs so if we
continue here then we see that there are
a number of different people including
cynthia alumnus senator out of wyoming
and others that are attempting to narrow
the scope of the law's crypto broker
clause with a separate bill that was
introduced yesterday another part of the
bill opposed by the crypto industry
requires recipients of transactions over
ten thousand dollars to verify the
sender's personal information and record
of their social security number the
nature of the transaction and other
information and then report the
transaction to the government within 15
days some lawyers have pointed out that
when applied to cryptocurrencies and
other digital assets like non-fungible
tokens it would be nearly impossible to
comply with these laws everyone's
yelling and screaming 1.2 trillion
dollars we're gonna go do all this great
infrastructure stuff oh first of all
it's not gonna contribute to inflation
wrong second it's gonna cost zero
dollars wrong third oh crypto tax are
gonna pay for it wrong why there's no
new tax there is no new tax here all
that is in this bill is more reporting
requirements so they're saying here are
the rules this is what is owed for taxes
we now need you to report more
information so that we can make sure
people are paying their taxes there's no
allegation that people are not paying
their taxes there's no allegation that
the government is missing out on tax
revenue it's simply trying to put more
onerous reporting rules now i agree that
these rules are incredibly onerous and
in many cases if applied in the most
broadest sense would not be possible a
minor has no clue
what is going on in terms of some of the
details that would be needed according
to these rules on top of that there's
other people who would fall under this
broker rule that cannot actually get the
information they don't know who the
social security number is in some cases
they don't even know who's sending them
the money and so you've got to start to
look at what are we trying to accomplish
and how effective or realistic is it on
top of that if we just increase
reporting that does not necessarily mean
that there is going to be more revenue
that is driven from this specifically
and so we've got a quote here joe biden
president united states said quote oh
once again have the best roads bridges
ports and airports will lead the world
into the 21st century with modern cars
and trucks and transit systems we're
already 20 of the way into the 21st
century right like i don't know if we're
leading anywhere like we're already in
the 21st century it's not like we're in
1999 and we're like you know hey let's
go let's go sign me up we're running
into no we're in 21st century like what
are you talking about uh second of all
is that well once again so are we saying
that we had the best roads bridges ports
and airports but now we don't who has
better ones and if they have better ones
why aren't they spending trillions and
trillions of dollars to keep theirs the
best so ultimately what we get is a 1.2
trillion dollar bill signed done sealed
delivered they're coming for it and
they're going to spend this money the
big question is how much of their plan
to pay for it is actually going to work
out versus it sounds good theoretically
but it's actually not going to come from
tax revenue that they believe
on top of that there's another 1.85
trillion dollar social spending package
that this week
the house is going to vote on so just
keep it rolling